I hi YouTube community my name is
Fernando need oh I'm a social
entrepreneur from the chat foundation
and i'm hearing the boss and i would
like to share my dream my ideas with the
community we are reciting the e-waste
the new ways of a central fax scanner he
cellular whatever you think is sonic
again on the life in our labor job these
people who was in jail they get the
freedom nobody offered a job and then we
offer second chance in life we are
recycling both people in the new a waste
of the century we will look to
communicate with you to invite to
recycling properly to invite to a twin
the global warming problem with
recycling recycling the solution for the
future I will love that term paper
entrepreneur CEO oyen everybody to think
about the greens here looking for
recycling and this is our future we
should work together a better world
together thank you bye